[Music]
wanna get rich playing video games erase
slaughterous it is wicked dangerous
[Music]
start turning buttock and put on your
church shoes little sister because we're
about to blast off what is it you're
trying to say we're going to the
Internet
[Music]
this is the most beautiful miracle I've
ever seen
welcome to the search bar what can I
help you find today Oh umbrella
Umbridge Oh mommy no no is art no doubt
no it's from rack
ergonomics Urban Outfitters oh cool I'm
pretty sure he's just trying to guess
what you're gonna say my auto failures
you touch aggressive today let me try
take me to a website that's super
intense and really nuts oh I only found
one result
come on cartoon characters
[Music]
hi ladies I'm a princess - what kind of
a princess are you huh
do you have magic hair no magic hands
no do animals talk to you know where you
fall isn't no cursed no kidnapped or
enslave no are you guys okay call the
police
do people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up the Internet shouldn't be Ralph Rex
the Internet
yes since he is wreck-it Ralph uh yeah
but break the Internet it's like a thing
right it's just wreck seeing it kind of
sounds better doesn't it
you're not wrong
you